Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and Welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
Statistics and probability have been used
in applications beyond the ones we usually
think of like research science and business
analytics.
One of the most consequential applications
of statistics is helping countries survive
and win wars.
Today, we’ll talk about how people applied
statistics to break codes, locate sunken submarines,
and even predict the next big war.
INTRO
Our first story is pretty well known in the
fields of computer science and statistics.
In World War II, the Germans used what looked
like a complicated typewriter to encode their
messages.
These machines, called Enigmas, allowed the
Germans to type in messages and receive encoded
ones back.
You may have done some simple encoding in
your childhood.
Like, if you wanted to send a message to your
friend that says “I like, like Alex” but
you don’t want Alex or anyone else for that
matter to be able to read the message.
You could create a key so that each letter
is represented by another letter like this:
If you wanted to write “I like” you’d
find those letters in the top row, and write
down their counterparts.
“I like” becomes “Y tymf” which makes
no sense...unless you have the key.
Your entire message would go from this:
“I like, like Alex.”
To this:
“Y tymf, tymf ptfw.”
So you’re safe to deliver your message.
But sometimes decoding messages has much higher
stakes than protecting crushes.
Like when there’s a war going on.
So by necessity, the keys--or methods of encryption--are
much more complex.
During the Enigma Encryption process, a letter
was sent through three rounds of encoding--similar
to how we encoded our message about Alex.
But the enigma had three Rotors, or wheels,
doing the encoding.
And the enigma machines would rotate the wheels
systematically after EVERY LETTER.
A letter that appeared in the original message
twice could get encoded as two totally different
letters.
There were 26 settings on each wheel, one
setting for every letter in the alphabet.
So there were 17,576 possible starting settings
(just for the wheels!) making it impossible
to figure out a message by manually trying
each start point.
If you wanted to decode a message, you needed
to know how those wheels were set.
The Germans also had multiple wheel options
AND plugboards, making things even more complicated.
Alan Turing and his team developed a technique
called Banburismus for deciphering messages
from the German Navy - which exploited the
fact that sometimes pairs of messages would
have chunks of text within them that had been
encoded with the same settings.
They used a very time-consuming method to
find these pairs.
Every intercepted message got hole punched,
in order, into paper that was lined with horizontal
alphabets.
Then, one message was placed on top of another
message, so a person could see how often holes
overlapped.
Why?
Well, two messages that were encoded with
different Enigma settings would only have
letters that matched by random chance.
The German navy had a primary Enigma that
they were using known as “Dolphin.”
Two messages encoded by the same Dolphin settings
had a 1/17 chance of having randomly matching
letters.
If two messages were encoded using DIFFERENT
settings, there’s a 1/26 change of having
randomly matching letters.
So, more matches than 1/26 would be increasing
evidence that the messages were encoded using
the same settings.
The Enigma codebreakers used that knowledge
to determine whether two intercepted messages
were more likely to be encoded using the same
or different settings.
They were also able to use other knowledge
in the decoding process.
Like, the team already knew that 90% of Enigma
messages contained the German word “ein,”
which can mean “one,” “a,” or “an.”
Plus, there were phrases about the weather
that were getting repeated often in messages.
‘Cuz, boats.
When Turing and his team determined it was
50 times more likely that the messages were
encoded with the same settings than not, they
considered it almost certain they’d found
a match.
They had a machine called “the bombe”
that could automatically cycle through a bunch
of those wheel settings in order to decode
messages.
But it took a LONG time to go through all
of the possibilities, so being able to narrow
them down was a necessary step.
As Mike Lee and Benedict King put it in their
article in The Conversation, “Turing’s
crucial Bayesian insight was that certain
messages were much more likely than other
messages.”
All this knowledge helped the team figure
out how the Enigma’s wheels were set when
it encoded a given message.
Using Bayesian reasoning helped Turing’s
team crack the Enigma code, and limited the
amount of settings they had to test by hand.
Some historians think cracking the Enigma
may have shortened the War by 2-3 years, saving
millions of lives.
In WWII, German U-boats were systematically
taking down Allied ships, including unarmed
merchant ships with supplies.
While some ships escaped unharmed like the
Empress of Scotland which carried Turing from
New York back to Europe the Allied forces
suffered many losses.
Locating the U-boats was not an easy task,
but the mathematician B.O.
Koopman used Bayesian reasoning.
Koopman would first ask experts where the
U-boat was likely headed.
With limited time and resources, prior information
and beliefs about the U-boat were important.
Koopman commented that: “Police will patrol
localities of high incidence of crime.
Public health officials will have ideas in
advance of the likely sources of infection
and will examine them first.”
And he wanted to do the same with the German
U-boats.
Using signals from the ship, Koopman was able
to target a 236 mile radius for planes to
search.
But that’s still big.
He would assign a 50-50 probability that the
U-boat was inside the circle, then he would
use all of the military information that he
had access to in order to update those beliefs.
That way he could make the best decisions
with whatever information he currently had.
Think about the last time you lost your keys.
You could plot out a grid that represented
your apartment, and you could assign a probability
that your keys are in each 1 foot by 1 foot
square based on the likelihood of possible
ways you misplaced them.
So maybe your keys fell out of your bag, which
would put them somewhere in this square.
Or maybe your cat got into your bag and dumped
its contents onto the floor.
Then they’d be in this square.
Or maybe you left them in your jacket pocket.
Then they’d be here.
Based on how likely you think these scenarios
are...and the knowledge that your cat loves
to push things off of tables... the best guess
is that the cat knocked over your bag again...you
can use Bayesian reasoning to create a probability
map of where your keys are most likely to
be.
You could also include information about how
likely you are to find your keys if you searched
for them in that square.
Keys that fell behind the refrigerator might
be hard to find even if you did search there.
It’d also be really hard to find your keys
if they went down a drain outside your door.
Combining all this information would leave
you with a map of your apartment that tells
you the best places to search.
This same theory--called Bayesian Search Theory--
was also applied by John Craven to find a
missing nuclear submarine in 1968.
Craven collected experts’ opinions on what
happened to the USS Scorpion, and used Bayesian
Search Theory to create a map of where the
sub would likely be found.
And it worked! Craven found the sub right
next to where he expected it.
Often in war it’s also essential to know
approximately how MANY of these vehicles exist.
Your strategy might be different if your enemy
had 1000 tanks than if they had only 200.
During WWII, Allied forces used traditional
techniques such as spying and interrogating
captured German soldiers and estimated that
the Germans were producing about 1,400 tanks
a MONTH.
But that seemed high.
Luckily, the Allies had already captured some
tanks with serial numbers on them.
So they used some clever math to estimate
the actual total number of tanks.
Assuming that the tanks’ serial numbers
went in order which was a reasonable assumption
they could use the range of the serial numbers
to estimate how many there were.
For example, if we found 4 tanks with the
serial numbers 7, 17, 47, and 65.
We’d know there are at LEAST 65 tanks.
But it’s possible there are 67 tanks.
Or 102 tanks.
Or 500 tanks.
We need a way to estimate what the most likely
maximum is.
There are many ways to do this, but one simple
one is to use this formula, where m is the
maximum serial number you observed ours is
65 and n is the number of observations you
made.
We made 4.
So our best guess at how many tanks there
are based on the data we collected is 80.25
we’ll round that to 80.
Because you can’t have .25 tanks.
When the Allies used similar techniques, they
estimated that there were 256 tanks being
made per month.
A much more accurate estimate.
The Germans were actually making about 255
tanks a month at the time.
And note to self: when fighting a war, do
not use sequential serial numbers - unless
you’re fighting raccoons - they can’t
read.
Jumping forward in time, to today.
Some researchers use statistical models to
predict when the next big war will be.
It has been a long time since the last major
World War.
Aaron Clauset of the University of Colorado
has set out to examine other stretches of
peace.
And this isn’t as simple as just counting
the years between major wars and calculating
the average time of peace.
Clauset looked for trends and correlations
that might predict the number of years between
major conflicts..
He found that across history, huge stretches
of peace were not unusual.
In fact it was downright common to see 100
to 140 years of peace following a large scale
war.
This long stretch of time without large-scale
world war is more rule than exception.
Statistics has many important applications.
War being one particularly high stakes application.
Mathematicians and Statisticians played a
huge role in WWII, and they continue to be
a part of defense departments and military
planning to this day.
Out of necessity, we often make huge strides
in the fields of math and statistics during
wars.
They force us to solve problems we may not
have needed to solve in times of peace.
Things like the Bayesian Search Theory that
Koopman worked is also used in times of peace
like in helping us find missing planes.
And the code breaking done by Turing and his
team was not only important in introducing
statisticians to Bayesian inference, but it
provided foundations for future code breaking
and encryption work that’s being done today.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you next time.